two
hello hello
this is friday we're both early and late
at the same time
that's a new one
today's episode is sponsored by honey
and hbo max
who we love so well
uh forgive me for being late
lots of stuff going on
that's all i'll say about that
um
going to be doing a little bit of a
shorter you got to limit us to like i
don't know maybe we should just do an
hour and a half today because oh my god
we got a we got something going on and i
got a heart out today gotcha but we did
do like 10 24 hour episodes guys this
week so
oh gabe's already here hey baby what's
up
wait hold on hold on
it's too early to be dropping f-bombs in
the app um
hold on hold on gabe no
wait uh five seconds wait bring it back
bring gabe out bring gabe out bring him
back in five minutes he's on too early
for that for the
we're over a minute in we are okay hey
baby
[Music]
damn you're making your great house
damn it's falling apart right now i'm
just frustrated about it don't lie don't
collapsing oh no foundation
[ __ ]
don't lie you ate that you ate that roof
and i don't blame you that thing looks
delicious
oh yeah
oh yeah so you're in the you're in the
christmas spirit huh
oh yeah definitely christmas spirit
everybody's happy christmas weekend baby
[ __ ] baby
let me see the house what you working on
you got the
are those little jelly beans or little
candy chews
it's kind of like candy chews which is
kind of like part of the and then put
some light christmas lights
and the roof is falling off oh man
well it's easy access for santa if you
want to be up
optimistic
oh yeah that'd be a good idea yeah you
can get the whole damn sleigh in that
house huh
you can just go through the attic and
then through the to the
to the fireplace i guess through the
stairs yeah absolutely you get more
presents i think when you have no roof
it's just easier access
oh yeah
right now it's just frustrating they've
got cheap frosting that's like glue i
wish they make edible glue or something
[ __ ] you can eat i think you can eat
yeah you can eat glue you can eat
elmer's yeah yeah you can eat all
numbers yeah i don't recommend it though
yeah
yeah well we got to work on that you
know it's it technology is not caught up
in the gingerbread house departments has
it
it's like so old-fashioned you know
old-fashioned back in the days
yeah
so what are your christmas plans
christmas press we're gonna have a
family get together at the house
exchanging girls [ __ ] it's gonna be a
christmas weekend
oh yeah [ __ ] baby yeah
a special weekend edition
have you heard that song i made love to
mrs claus
i make love to mrs claus
yeah baby let's get it
all right well i'm happy you're having a
good time i'm happy you're in the
christmas spirit you lifted my spirits
that's for sure oh we have wait we have
a gabe update
um hold on oh [ __ ]
you were hungover here gabe posted this
this morning this doesn't this ain't
look like no christmas spirit to me what
happened from last night
goes from last night and
partying too hard thursday night
thursday nights like
friday
the weekend starts thursday night damn i
guess
some people say thursday's a new friday
do you oh yeah
i agree definitely since
some some communities are doing
implementing the three-day weekend
four-day work week oh interesting
thursday thursday that's right thursday
thursday so how much so how much did you
drink last night it looks like you're in
bad shape
i had like
five six shots whoa
[ __ ] holy crap
this man knows how to live i'm with you
gabe man
well fridays are for legends as one of
the comments says and that means it's
your day so [ __ ] baby woo [ __ ] baby
[ __ ] yeah
let's see how straight this house will
stay at before before it totally
collapses yeah you better
yeah get to work with that with that uh
with that frosting okay i have faith in
you you're gonna you're gonna build back
better
you need to build back better bill for
that gingerbread house that's right give
me some confidence babe all right i
believe in you
all right bud you take care you have a
great weekend you enjoy christmas okay
you uh thanks for lifting our spirits
here on this friday afternoon
yeah merry christmas baby merry
christmas buddy
[Music]
all right gabe
all right love you buddy you have a
great weekend okay see you baby yeah i
have a good one too all right oh we're
seeing you in person next week right
oh yeah
i got a present for you we're doing a
gift exchange right
oh yeah
you got me something good right
yeah well we will find out next week all
right give me something good
a rolex maybe
something maybe something like that okay
all right sick
can't wait
all right all right take care buddy
friday friday it's friday baby
all right take care bye bye all right
bye-bye bye
love that man
man this picture is pretty iconic dude
that's a that's just raw that's a raw
update pain no one can party like that
you got a bug or something or maybe it's
just like a little and
something on his skin yeah yeah
when we were at the party he was just
doing consecutive [ __ ] shots like
he's a party animal he's a legend and
he's 50 years old too which again
apparently the secret to youth is just
getting drunk every weekend
because he looks great for 50.
he looks younger than me i would say
i'm 36 you know
all right
that was a treat
god bless god bless gabe gabriel
so um
yeah as you can see
by the title
we had a rough morning
in that regard
i've been reported to the fbi
uh oh
uh by none other than
ryan kavanagh
you know most people are spending time
with their family
right kavanaugh is [ __ ] posting
and tagging the [ __ ] fbi
and urging people to uh send tips about
me being a meanie to the fbi now
is being a mania federal crime
that's where he was mistaken i believe
it's only a state crime
oh so that if that's not even in the
fbi's jurisdiction he would want to
report that to the
uh attorneys attorney general attorney
general
of california yeah that would be the
proper channel this is the first time
actually it's the third time actually oh
all right well he says it's the first
time he says it's the first time oh
right right that's true he does say it's
the first time yeah that's true
ryan cavanaugh says at h3 podcast of
course he blocked me so i'm assuming he
just
says he's inciting violence again bro
you gotta stop saying that
you gotta stop saying i'm inciting
violence
it's violence to say that he looks like
harvey weinstein that's
violence that's
that's violence defamatory he can say
it's defamatory it's not but saying i'm
inciting violence no that's defamatory
on his part oh absolutely it is
absolutely it is i mean
what well anyway he goes
hp podcast is inciting violence hate and
threats
me and almost anyone i know getting the
same threats and hate
and then of course he tags
uh instagram
at youtube at twitter as he
uh the head of a media company knows
that's the best way to
get the attention of huge media
companies is to tag their
main app
also he tagged reddit
so i'm sure those are going straight to
the top of the food chain absolutely
he says please act before this causes
more harm
and he links this video and he says file
complaints here fbi.gov
tips
i'm sure they have their top men on that
by now
well as you found out when they raided
you this morning
kicked in your door
yeah they came they said there was an it
was one of those 8 am knocks and they go
they go open up fbi
we have reports that someone in here is
being a meanie come out with your hands
up
there was helicopters overhead they
blocked off the whole street
there was basically 20 police cars fully
armored
swat teams everywhere it's traumatic
this is live footage from europa
it was this is exactly what happened
this morning
this is exactly what happened that is
basically the best
characterization of what's happened at
my house this morning so you can see
there's been a lot happening
ela is not here today because uh
she's being detained by the big
questions
yeah
yeah so
i'm out on bail
10 million dollar bail i uh i
sold everything gabe put up the money
actually he helped out i uh yeah again
gabe's had a crazy year on cameo so he
was able to uh
give me a bail bond yep what a king that
was some serious [ __ ]
and um
i'm out on bail but i'm facing you know
30 to life on this meanie
charge
yeah
oh look at that speaking of gabe
apparently he's finally got that white
claw sponsorship that gave him his own
flavor
gingerbread wait is that a real flavor
yeah
yeah they just launched it
is this a real flavor i i hope no
because that would be disgusting well i
don't know i mean like you know okay
gabe is crushing it bro that's a pretty
cool promo
yeah do you believe this guy ryan i mean
are you [ __ ] serious can you imagine
the fbi like
all the [ __ ] they have to deal with
these days you know and now they've got
ryan cavanaugh
telling people to fill out
tips
[Music]
what what do you suppose you wrote in
that tip field
hit me with that sad keemstar music
dear fbi
my name
is ryan kavanagh
there it is
before i utterly bankrupted
relativity media
[Music]
i was just a good old boy
who started a hedge fund with my daddy's
money
that he got by selling fake picassos
allegedly
allegedly with peace and love
just my opinion based on that article
it's also just a joke i'm just a
comedian
i'm not a news organization
and he goes
well i'm just a good old boy
i'm just i'm the underdog ceo or i'm the
majority owner of a huge media company
underdog
ryan cavanaugh
and he said i look like harvey weinstein
this has to be a federal offense he even
wrote in the field he wrote
if you go to google and type ryan
cavanaugh
in the search field
[Music]
and you scroll down
fbi if you're listening
and click
holy [ __ ] it's pretty high up there
his website's gone love
oh no it's down here we're ranking above
his website
number three that's
it's very unusual for you to jump down
that much
that's credibility
flick of the mouse and pop papa's in the
house
um so he goes dear fbi
do you really think i look that much
like harvey weinstein
and then the fbi agent comes to this
website he scrolls down
and he go and then he comes to this
and he says hmm
i do see the resemblance but this is a
federal climb crime
do you see it
[Music]
and the fbi agent goes hmm look at the
resemblance that is uncanny
then the fbi agent scrolls down and he
starts to read and look and he plays the
game at the bottom
spend some time on the website
and he says this ethan kidd he's a
menace to society
we've gotta lock him up no bail and
throw away the key ethan klein is as
damaging everything making it all worse
that i believe is from the fbi director
a direct quote that's right
the [ __ ] fbi you believe this guy
i mean like really let's take this in
he is telling people to file a tip
on fbi.gov about me
have we reached fully unhinged yet or is
there more ways is there further to go
yeah
that's
it's hard to say i've long said that the
quartering is like the platonic uh ideal
of an oaf
but this tweet
i don't know you may have superseded uh
jeremy
this is
top of this is top tier oh fishness it's
all dumb
[Music]
yeah so we need to free ela from the fbi
she's currently
they heard eli said um
what a deal ela said something like uh
she's like i don't like ryan kavanagh i
think on the last spot on the last after
dark and they got her now [ __ ] fbi got
her put her away for life she slipped up
i don't like it so thoughts and prayers
to ela for that
we have a beautiful moment in this
week's behind the scenes where ethan
reads that tweet for the first time
because he tweeted it while we were live
and so we were waiting till after the
episode to show ethan oh yeah we were
doing the cracker episode and then you
guys were like the new craziest
kavanaugh tweet just dropped i was like
what
um
and i read it live i was shocked
you know oh and then here's the craziest
part you guys this [ __ ] been
promote he's been paying to promote this
[ __ ]
he's been paying to promote his telling
people that
this guy we looked at this guy doesn't
know anything about anyone he said so i
don't know who this ryan guy is neither
do i know what the h3 podcast is nor who
this woman crying is but this guy prom
this is a promoted and the person has
replies turned off
are they paying to promote youtube or
drama
like the fact that he's paying to
promote it it's even just confusing like
i mean
to anyone who's not familiar which i
guess just stumbles across that but we
actually found uh it with the promoted
tab right
we found it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah how'd
you find it because we were looking for
that
actually a viewer sent it in i asked
that person who made that yeah they're
promoted awesome yeah
amazing what's funny is that you know
we've deleted everything but ryan's
promoted
twitter video lives on
it was at this moment that he knew so
he's really helping everyone there
what a guy
love him
oh this is one i've been sitting on this
this is good actually okay because i you
know let's go so keemstar
there's basically an axis of evil going
or okay
there's a collection of people that
don't like me going on wait they
self-describe themselves as the access
to people i don't think that it's
uncalled and they sell access of evil
merch
no i'm it's i'm not talking about like
leaf that was a leafy thing wasn't it
but keemstar no it was keemstar he calls
himself it was yeah it was keemstar
leafy and rice gum yeah yeah the content
company i think it's fair i think it's
fair to launch
that [ __ ] is dead and gone now right
like i don't know what happened to it
but like to self-describe yourself as
the axis of evil is to call yourself a
not a fascist nazi
yeah
which is
not something good
last time i checked things are quickly
changing though they think that through
did they but anyway keemstar of course
champion of creators rights is out here
defending rank
that there's absolutely there is no way
there is no way
here let's watch this from the top there
is no way that this absolute [ __ ]
clown is crying about somebody going
after his sponsorship shut up
h3h3 is the by the way i'm not cr i'm
not crying about him going after my
sponsors i i don't care okay
that's not working
but regardless he's delusional because
that's exactly what he did his only
defense against the content nuke was you
went after sponsors and then we found
out he's been doing that for years
so again yes we're back on the keem
cycle of delusion it's like a romeo
julia exactly
also no keem lost his sponsors because
of things that he did that got
called out right dude it was just g
fueled the dude had a bottle of g-fuel
while urging somebody to
basically un-alive themselves like how
could i not point that out
it was
i mean it was funny observation it
wasn't like i was like everybody go
email g fuel and tell them to drop keem
it was like right which is literally
what ryan did which is what ryan did
right
like so keemstar are you for this or
against it like you can't be like i'm
for it against ethan
and against it for everyone else like
you've got to pick your lane bro
the biggest hypocrite of youtube in may
of 2020 this [ __ ] uploads a
series of videos lying and you know just
getting all the facts wrong and putting
a weird spin on [ __ ] stories
surrounding me one of them accusing me
of murder of killing another youtuber
bro stop
funny that he says i accused him of
murder he's never able to point to
specific things either never he says i
got everything wrong i lied it's like
name one thing i lied about
bro well he's saying i accused him of
murder which is just
amazing causing an emotional response
from his fans and then at the same time
targeting my sponsor g fuel which all of
his fans started doxxing and harassing
and doxing doxxing
people okay
okay
i got threats to my [ __ ] spot that's
right
to lose my g-fuel sponsorship right
everybody called him out for this
critical call them out for this like
biggest youtubers on the planet called
him out don't do that that's bad for the
[ __ ] community but he just listens in
fact james charles then gets cancelled
for and again i think james charles is
guilty and deserved to get cancelled
dude pick a [ __ ] side yeah
everybody called him out they said he
shouldn't do this but now i support ryan
kavanagh doing it because i don't like
ethan yeah and he goes well james
charles deserved it but yeah ethan tried
to cancel james
for being an actual
you know i know you guys know about it
man let me read def's noodles definitely
description because he's always on it
keemstar claims ethan's being a hipper
of calling out kavanaugh for going after
sponsors ironically by supporting ryan
kavanaugh going after ethan sponsors kim
started supporting the very thing he's
accusing ethan of doing double irony kim
starts gone after sponsors and
celebrated when creators lost their
sponsors in the back yes yeah
i guess he's pretty entertaining though
keemstar yeah and also i got to say
great steady hand king the weight oh so
that makes you jealous it really does
because he's bobbing his head he's
losing it and still there is it possibly
is using a tool
i don't know he's a selfie stick kind of
guy for sure
that would be so [ __ ] funny if he was
all these snaps he had a selfie stick
well look where his arm is i think
because his arm is too low i think he
has a tool if his arm you can see his
arm is going down like if you're holding
it his arm would be like this but yet
it's down so he definitely has some kind
of tool his arm is is like this
he has a tool maybe maybe you should
invest in a tool lady
yeah
dude
he's not holding the camera my mind is
just [ __ ] blown right now if he's
using a truck look at look at his look
at the angle of his arm he's not holding
the camera he's holding a stick
or some kind of tool that's
shooting the phone
holding the phone in front of him
yeah
this is wild and stop at just telling
everybody what was going on no he went
after james charles sponsors he did it
again and bro you just said he deserved
to get cancelled
let's just
and now i'm hitler
well you are you did say axes of evil
and the david dobrik situation i'm not
exactly sure if he went after david
dobrik's well maybe you should look that
up news guy i never did go after david
dobrik sponsors sponsors i'm pretty sure
he did but right okay oh he's pretty
sure he goes ethan lies and gets
everything wrong about me
anyway i'm pretty sure he went after
david swanson he platformed the [ __ ]
reporters that definitely went after
david dobrik sponsors i mean this is an
ongoing thing so you're you hypocritical
piece of [ __ ] you don't get to cry about
someone else going after your sponsors
you don't get to do it you don't get to
say this is going to cause an apocalypse
guys guys community help me and here's
another thing with this lawsuit this
current lawsuit that's going on with
h3h3 his fans and him are complaining
that he's not getting community support
from other youtubers like he did in
2016. well in 2016 h3h3 is clowning on
that boss right
salty and then sue's h3h3 it was clearly
over fair use this new situation is
completely different oh god ethan didn't
stop it gosh i wonder
if he's been talking to ryan about it
interesting i don't think it's
completely different bro actually just
telling everybody what was going on no
he oh next one yeah okay he does have
like a boxing venture that's starting up
soon i wonder if um oh he said it's with
ryan cavanaugh
he literally said on his podcast oh he
did he said i have a project coming up
with ryan cavanaugh next month oh well
there you go
yeah
pirated the the the boxing fight the
trailer boxing fight promoted the idea
of pirating and not paying for it that's
not what he's being sued first of all
saying
bro
what does that have to do with copyright
infringement
isn't that what dramaalert is
like what is he arguing
it's not what i'm saying like that's all
he does is just watch clips on his show
yeah i mean it's you i don't know what
he's talking about
i don't think he's really familiar with
the lawsuit
well he's familiar with
what ryan
pirated the the boxing fight the trailer
boxing fight promoted the idea of
pirating and not paying for it and then
reap that's not a crime bro
it's also not what you're being sued for
no
so
huh
not actually it's almost like he's a
news guy that doesn't know what the [ __ ]
he's talking about the fight to millions
of people so he gets sued for that and
instead of just being like okay i'm
wrong i'm guilty no he decides to make
podcasts after podcast after pogba about
my best friend and good and my my helper
my best friend
bow in the house aka ryan kavanagh
hacking you know the people involved in
triller which causes him to get another
lawsuit this is not about fair use go
[ __ ] yourself the hypocritical piece of
[ __ ] and all your fans okay
oh and all your fans you heard it go
[ __ ] yourself and all your fans
you guys heard it so sassy
yeah but like obviously he's so
desperate to believe it's not about fair
use but it is of course and
about more i mean his defamation all
keemstar does is like basically defame
people or at least talk about people
like if keemstar if kavanaugh wins
against me on defamation that'll [ __ ]
keemstar harder than anyone with what he
does
you know what i mean huh
shut up [ __ ] oh yeah death noodles
each
shout out each keemstar falls with the
rock shut up [ __ ]
that's awesome
cool
yes you heard it there kim
said [ __ ] ethan and all of his fans i
think he's talking about you guys
nobody talks about my fans that way
i'll be the one to tell them to shut the
[ __ ] up
nobody else
or dan i think that's your job actually
right
i'm the good guy
so
all kinds of good stuff let's see
whoa yeah we actually figured out how
he shoots all those videos
he's got it right on his keychain
a pocket knife or a swiss army knife
with a selfie stick yeah
i like that actually
you should invest in that maybe
it looks custom
you think it's custom once you can get a
tool to hold a camera steady then
keemstar will have you'll have nothing
to covet from him
right i'm alert
yeah he probably he probably needs a new
host he might be good at it i mean
i'm good
okay you sure i mean you know
also a nice little cam uh we we've been
uncovering a lot of really cool
kavanaugh tweets
this one's awesome oh what did he tweet
well what the [ __ ] why is this why is he
posting like spam this copy pasta [ __ ]
it might be
too spicy for youtube yeah it's
responses it's pretty insane
yeah
it's basically like mega islamophobia
yeah it's just like a hardcore like
anti-islam rant i didn't see the top
part but you can tell it's um
you can tell it's credible based on the
wild fluctuation of fonts the
wild boldness
it's basically a q anon post here yeah i
wouldn't yeah there's parts of this that
if you read out loud we'd probably get
okay stung for his reply to he's pretty
epic i'm bottom he says there are 200
million plus extreme muslims and there
are
12 total jews yep
it's 12.
just 12. see me 12 million
he probably means 12 million because
that is a true he was sauced up when he
was yeah
as usual
that's speculation by the way
i love that there's 200 mil isn't there
there's 200 million muslims and only 12
jews
the odds are stacked against us people
and it keeps calling you racist it's
like this dude has like all these anti
black letters tweets he hates muslims
it's crazy
yeah and funnily enough he doesn't know
how to erase tweets so they're still up
there
right i know it's very strange
he's an odd man
a very odd man
when you're drunk it's hard to
do fine uh motor skills like hitting the
delete button oh maybe the three little
dots yeah that stuff some say he's still
there oh god i gotta go
he takes a sip he click he's oh man he
just passes out tries the next day
the problem is as soon as he wakes up he
takes another drink and then it's a
vicious cycle
drinking semen is a good idea
as a percent there is as many violent
nazis as there are
violent muslims what does that mean
as it as a percent
he's a great thinker though wait um so
he's saying there's 200 million extreme
muslims
i think that there's about a billion
muslims in the world and so he's saying
oh one out of but hold on so he's five
so he's saying one out of every five
nazis are violent
as a percent as many
nazis
which is a very you like that ryan very
strong is he defending nazis well only
the non-violent ones only the four out
of five that aren't violent [ __ ] own
his ass dan so he's saying he's
basically what is he trying all muslims
all muslims are nazis basically no he's
saying 200 million of them are like
violent nazis which are the bad nazis
has ever sent as many violent nazis
as violent muslims that's that's why my
family calls dan habib dan
what's habib how do you even mean
sweetheart oh you're a habibi a bibi or
nadeeb
what i'm not there yet
you're a habit to me bad
i'm habibi to me you would be a habit
girl there's this term in uh in judaism
for like righteous uh gentiles like they
call them like a a righteous gentile
i think you're a righteous gentile maybe
thank you thank you like for example who
would be a righteous gentile like uh you
know schindler
oscar schindler he gets that
right he's a righteous gender right what
is the term for it they're it's i've
heard that before isn't it [ __ ]
no that's just a gentile right yeah
they're elevated gentile
elevated going
it's the same thing a gentile is a
non-jew yeah yeah
i'm just asking if you know the yiddish
word for it
i know i'm familiar with [ __ ]
righteous gentile it's actually really
interesting the whole
let me see
oh yeah that's it's called a
no hide
a gentile who has forsaken ideal tree
while living among his own people
following the sons of noah what the [ __ ]
religion's so weird
oh here righteous among the nations is
an honorific used by the state of israel
to describe non-jews who risked their
lives during the holocaust to save jews
from extermination right there you go
okay yeah righteous among the nations
shout out to schindler that's a cool
that's a cool [ __ ] title they have
like a big ass mural to
oscar schindler and israel and
it's pretty cool that's cool yeah
[Laughter]
well calm down there hassan
not don't get so happy about the guy
hassan
[Laughter]
hassan pecker
that's such a good soundbite
he's got some gems man
crack up
yep and you know what man i'm sorry but
there's just one more thing ryan
cavanaugh has now gotten into the that
she's responding to reviews on
i mean obviously i'm speculating but
like who who amongst their support team
would write a comment like this in
response to a review do you think gamers
aim directly i mean i do i do
i do actually i do you can't say for
sure but when you look at this it's it's
like who else would feel as confident to
say something like this unless you were
of course are there a lot of typos
because that would probably confirm it
well of course like the grammar is
correct it's i would say it's not him
okay so let's read okay yeah let's just
say of course i don't know for sure i
mean how could i know i don't work a
trail i don't have access to their
things but
do i think ryan left this yes
for sure so unprofessional and buggy the
camera kept facing the wrong direction
when i tried to use it i talked to
support and they completely disregarded
my issue and made fun of my english
not my only language i would one million
rather use tick tock for entertainment i
tried to use the app for fun and
enjoyment but actually it upsets me a
lot people aren't nice at all i felt
like i was getting attacked and told it
was my fault actually bullied for a
genuine review
and then triller llc responds hi maddie
i'm sorry you didn't enjoy the app no
one has reported a mirroring issue in
the app to trailer since it first
occurred months ago so i'm not sure you
have a problem there also one thousand
one million percent is not a real
percentage
so and then of course one million
percent is a real percentage yeah yeah
you can go yeah that's why i think it's
kavanaugh
i'm starting to come around yeah it's
starting to come around based off of
that percent like it clearly is a real
percentage you can have a million
percent of something it just means that
it's that many more times the original
amount right like it's it's definitely a
real that's like saying oh and a million
isn't a real number
it's like the way that face banks
thinks he's infinitely smarter than you
right right
i'm infinitely smarter than you and i'm
infinitely more successful than you
i think he's mistaking how you can't
have more you can't have of a
tangible object
you can't give more than 100 effort
right so when people say i'm giving a
billion percent efforts like you can't
give more than a hundred percent effort
what the [ __ ] is the maximum effort you
can give but if if you say i have you
know
if i have 10 pieces of rice i can have a
million percent
more pieces of rice oh wow you're ready
with that
so if you get inside the mainframe you
hit the chalkboard right now no i'm on
to something and hold on i'm about to
have a breakthrough
if you go to the whiteboard and you
start m equals m c squared
and if you think about block the density
of black hole and how is it tears the
time the time space continuum
you can understand how a million percent
can be real although maybe if you go
deeper into the black hole where the
the the the fabric of space time and
physics breaks down
maybe he's right that in the event
horizon that a million is not a real
number that could be true in that one
instance
unless
you're traveling 88 miles per hour
and you get struck with a bolt of
lightning that's 1.21 gigawatts
and potentially it could go in reverse
otherwise
wow that was good zach
what the f
that was fast
yeah maybe he's talking about uh
back to the future i don't know
interesting stuff huh
guys come on you gotta admit this is
interesting stuff here today interesting
stuff here today fascinating thank you
olivia absolutely thank you for
supporting me
always
yeah
oh i guess i should talk about this a
shout out to ela
ceo entrepreneur
teddy fresh shout out to hildy final
drop of the year
teddyfresh.com
funding lawsuits everywhere
uh we've got the sherpa half zip my
friends this is a beautiful piece
gorgeous comfy multi-colored white
white's a brave color of choice for the
sherpa but if you feel brave it's
beautiful
you know what i'm saying it's like
it's risky it's a lot of real estate to
stain
absolutely but this is my fave color
and if you keep looking
this graphic is hard to appreciate in
the social post but it's a really
beautiful embroidery
you got the teddy fresh bear you got all
the fun little graphics which we love
so well
funding lawsuits everywhere
head on over to teddyfresh.com
last drop of the year
women's plaid zip jacket
look at this zipper bro we developed
custom zippers
with a teddy bear head
it's kind of hard to see i guess but
another beautiful piece
elacline
uh what's going on with my computer i
don't know
here boom ooh
cool oh take photos work it work it
you got the women shrunken plaid vest
this is pretty popular i see women
wait is this yeah this is for women
and more men
you know size up if you're a guy i'm
assuming you got the sherpa pants the
matching pants the magic pants this is
one i designed
and i thought it was going to flop bad i
made a bunch of shirt designs a while
ago
you can tell i designed that right
always late
i drew it
out
and
it actually turned out pretty good i
mean people like it which is i was like
oh god
little you know
the melting clock
that's cool it's a i made a bunch of
designs called teddy fresh rx you'll see
which is about how i am on a shitload of
antidepressants every day and i wanted
to express myself this is just one piece
of like the collection i guess more will
be coming out later that's cool man
thank you did you uh
the the
the egg salad or dolly part you designed
that too yes i did
that's pretty dope i mean so basically i
did rough sketches and i'm a horrible
artist so then we sent it to
a better artist too
nice but they kind of did try to capture
my style they just made it nicer so that
was cool
yeah i'm happy actually that turned out
pretty fun
oh and then there's a watch here it's a
broken watch on the sleeve let me see
there's a picture of it
i think i saw it oh yeah
broken
yeah
yeah that's awesome
so shout out you know
yeah i design stuff every every once in
a while
oh this one's restocked the cat applique
everyone loves this one don't touch me
so nice so good
so good
he's so good
and basically oh this was like a mega
hit that we restocked the women's
patchwork zip up this is like
it's beautiful you wear that one don't
you olivia or a different i wear it in
the other color but i do also love this
one you can have one if you want i would
love
yeah just tell lina
yeah so there you guys go teddyfresh.com
funding lawsuits
everywhere
she also have uh some sponsor reads that
we should do okay so let's thank our
sponsors uh let's start with honey
oh wait i want to show this one this
one's not in stock is it uh a b but
it looks so good
look at these
oh it is on the website stuff yeah lina
looks amazing and our
i forget what it's called
and then our swami you guys know swami
he's locked he's loaded he's looking
good he's actually wearing the same
hoodie i am now
it's the uh thermal lined
[Applause]
zip up hoodie which is awesome it's warm
it's cozy it's comfy really cool the
thermal lining i apologize i don't see
it on the website
yeah i think that one's oh my sold out
there's
well it's a great picture i mean i don't
mind
i'm not mine thank you
um
anyway thank you to honey
we all shop online and watching that
promo code field taunts us at checkout
but thanks to honey manually searching
for coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the f i wonder if honey knows
i'm a out of fbi fugitive
i probably shouldn't mention that during
the sponsor read well i'm a fugitive
from the fbi i'm on the run as we speak
thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is
the thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
and finds to your car honey supports
over 30 000 stores online ranging from
tech gaming products popular fashion
brands and even food delivery
imagine you're shopping on one of your
favorite sites and when you go to the
checkout the honey button drops down and
all you gotta do is click apply coupon
dude that's right stephen
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons that can find for that site and
if honey finds a working coupon
watch that price drop immediately
eat up yo we got a discount on postmates
indeed
that is unbelievably epic
here's a good percentage too
yeah i mean it's it's insane if you're
not using honey you're literally missing
out on free money it's so easy
it's seamless you just install it a
couple clicks
and when you check out it just
automatically looks for coupon codes
applies them if they can find it
and that's it i mean we save money on
clothing specifically clothing a lot i'm
surprised we got 15 14 18 12 bucks off
damn food that's crazy
insane
uh honey has founded 17 million members
over two billion dollars in savings
eat your heart out jeff bezos whoa
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free installs in
a few seconds and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
this podcast i never recommend something
i don't use get honey for free at
joinhoney.com h3ad that's join honey.com
h38d
and finally
thank you to hbo max
love hbo max i love this song that he
plays on the ads well it's my favorite
one yeah an hbo i i got to tell you it's
it's my favorite streaming service right
now
i go there there's always something good
if it's not an hbo max they got these
hub networks i get all my anime they got
crunchyroll on the hub network you can
watch all these new anime shows
freaking there's one on there called uh
cali what's it called um
i just said golly i know was that one of
the categories i think it was
uh two infinity or something no what was
it called
[ __ ]
where it's about this orb that's sent to
the earth to experience you guys never
heard of the show it was so good
it's insanely good um
orb that goes to earth to learn
anime
uh to your eternity to your eternity
okay like i haven't heard people talking
about this but it's insanely good have
you guys seen to your internet first i'm
hearing about it
it's on hbo max with the real
crunchyroll and it's like freaking
beautiful nice
um
do people watch this show i'm like so
confused why nobody knows this show uh
i'm seeing
i'm seeing that some people in the chat
saying yeah it's like they love it
freaking
it's one of those shows i was like why
is everyone not talking about this show
but besides that
they've got dune many saints of new work
succession season three insecure season
five curve season 11 they've got the
matrix
oh yeah
coming out
next week next week freaking week
oh i'm
you know i'm watching that [ __ ] day one
with my popcorn i'll be talking oh come
on neil come on neil you're the chosen
one you gotta do it yo you gotta you
gotta gotta jump you gotta beat them
they believe neo yo they oughta
i also have the new uh sex and the city
spin-off show and just like that very
good highly recommend it oh was that i
heard a lot of people talking about it
yeah it's really good i have to say it's
really good nice yeah but the matrix
no samantha though right you gotta
believe samantha samaria
is starting to believe wait which one
samantha the red head no the blonde the
the other blonde not the main one but
the other one
it's still really good highly
recommended did she die in the show or
something no that's a plot point that
that's someone else
oh [ __ ] spoiler well that is a spoiler
just saying that i feel like a lot of
people have seen it by now i'm just oh
jesus zack you just spoiled the [ __ ]
show he's gonna go watch it now oh my
gosh exactly did you watch the original
uh yes
did you love it yeah i i didn't my
parents used to watch that i'd be like
i'm too young for this [ __ ]
good show anyway guys there's so much to
watch there it's it's honestly insane
uh it's got all your favorites it's got
something for everyone it's all in one
place you can download top titles and
watch it on your devices to go as well
so don't miss out on taking your
entertainment game to the next level hbo
max is the streaming home of over 13 000
hours of addictive series blockbuster
movies an exclusive original start
streaming on your favorite device today
sign up at hbom
dot ax slash h3 ad2
the urls get more insane every time i
read it
but don't worry the link is in the
description yes as of just a second ago
actually i just added it thank you dan
yeah so once again sign up at hd hb okay
so h b o m
dot a x slash h three a d two very easy
to remember
links in the description and we love you
hbo max so thank you
yeah
yeah
come on
can
i just say real quick that both those
sweaters are still available on the
website i was wrong you're wrong wait
which way
which ones the ones that one lena was
mina and swamy i'm wearing the one
swami's yeah i don't know your hands
wait lena's is still on the website yeah
oh it's yeah it's from a previous drop
i'm pretty sure i think the last one
oh that's interesting oh here it is okay
it's this one because it's a different
color being displayed right this is the
one that she was wearing oh yeah they
are both on there oh thank you for
making that update amy that's that's
important very important critical
information
thank you and it's beautiful
houndstooth cardigan
she's so beautiful so beautiful
all right well what do we got here today
we got uh
jake paul said he's gonna
i'm so not watching this fight not and
not because i got sued the last time i
did
um jake paul is now fighting
the same [ __ ] guy again
before he i was actually interested in
that fight when he was gonna fight uh
tyson fury's brother tyson fury's like
the world champ right now
an interesting guy entertaining guy and
i was like his brother's gonna kill jake
i really thought he was
and now he's fighting the same guy he
beat last time
i mean who gives a [ __ ] bro nobody's
watching this we just added to his
contract that if he can knock me out
he'll get 500k bonus on top
so that's that i don't need nothing i
already got everything
does that
i just bet i beat his ass that's my bed
i'm i'ma i'm gonna eat your ass i mean
i'm gonna beat your ass
i'm not falling for that
do you wanna let me from that part
was that a joke or a slip up i think he
was joking yeah yeah yeah yeah but it's
[Laughter]
i liked his response though i'm not
following yeah i guess jake has always
been like i'm doing the sussy joke i'm
doing the ada ross sassy sassy
[Music]
i'm gay isn't that crazy
isn't that funny oh yeah didn't he post
that tick tock where he he said he
hooked up a little nausea
yeah that was like
that's actually straight weird psycho
yeah
it's pretty odd
a little
nause
but if this were actually an accident
then that's so funny
well he no i don't think it was because
he was doing it the last time it was
yeah definitely i'm sassy
careful i might give you a kiss on the
lips buddy
isn't that crazy that i might be
attracted to you um
being gay is scary
it's intimidating to you isn't it
um
anyway i'm not watching that
[ __ ] that
but i'm sure
as [ __ ] hell
sure that the uh critical part will be
uploaded to tick tock and twitter and
every [ __ ] imaginal corner of the
internet
that i have nothing to do with because
that's just the way the internet works
so if i happen to see it in one of those
places
maybe i'll watch it but i don't support
pirating so stop it
well
stop it
here we have some light-hearted groups
let's do that how would being a micro
influencer wound me up a micro
influencer stop you're not an influencer
if you're a micro influencer
guys you don't need that [ __ ] we got to
get rid of that
micro influencer is not a thing
there's already too many people who want
to be influencers that are causing like
uh
that are ruining this planet
right and influencers do enough harm i'm
proof of that
no micro influencer i refute this title
you don't even want to be an influencer
at all there's nothing more embarrassing
than being a micro influencer
just say you're making videos
okay
at what point does a micro influencer
become an influencer do you think well i
was going to ask you what what is the
definition of micro influence or just
someone just someone who [ __ ]
literally has 10 i don't know i mean
says i was like
i was curious what this account has and
she has like six thousand eight hundred
girl that's just like people at your
high school
yeah you've got you've got a lot of
friends yeah
that's like your grandma and some of her
friends follow you doesn't i mean okay
how being a micro influencer landed me
in the hospital yesterday i went to
whole foods and then italy and then i
bought this stunning rug that actually
fit perfectly in my condo i started
filming my first unboxing tiktok the
bulb in this umbrella exploded i ordered
sushi and facetimed this guy who
explained to me that the powder and
liquid i cleaned out of the light bulb
with my bare hands could kill me an hour
later the symptoms of mercury poisoning
started and when i really could not
breathe anymore i called 9-1-1 and went
to the emergency room i was diagnosed as
delusional so i came home and went to
bed
how being a microwave
oh my god
this is your brain on micro influence
i gotta read this again i gotta watch
a lot of twists and turns today i went
to whole foods and then italy and then i
bought this stunning rug that actually
fit perfectly in my condo i started
filming my first unboxing tiktok the
bulb in this umbrella exploded i ordered
sushi and facetimed this guy who
explained to me that at this point i
understand why she's a micro influencer
i'm gonna say it
i love her okay well maybe not so funny
maybe she's about to ascend
to full-blown influencer
i am ready to subscribe i am ready to
follow her go give her that phone well
there you go underscore jules mary she's
gonna get the h3 bump now just so many
cliches one after another too much sorry
for the lack of content i didn't know i
was going to be making this she said in
the description okay here we go
that the powder and liquid i cleaned out
of the light bulb with my bare hands
could kill me an hour later a powder
light bulb out of a
[Music]
powder out of a light bulb could kill
her that sounds nice mercury in the
light bulb uh yeah well how what i mean
how old is this light bulb shoes
cleaning
i don't think there's deadly amounts of
mercury well i mean light bulb
she as she says at the end the hospital
was like you're delusional go home yeah
so don't hold on with my bare hands
could kill me an hour i'm not gonna see
the video you're waiting for bestie yet
later the symptoms of mercury poisoning
started and when i really could not
breathe anymore i called 9-1-1 and went
to the emergency room she took a [ __ ]
ambulance she called 9-1-1
oh here hear from ab light bulbs contain
an inert gas or argon and this isn't
very dangerous so long as there's oxygen
around as well of course there's plenty
in the air so there isn't mercury in
life oh well some no some light bulbs do
have a small amount of from when 1920
no
i've seen cfls which those are still in
circulation
what is the cfl what does that thing
look like
what are her other videos like
yeah hold on i want to finish this and
we'll just go down the rabbit hole
they put mercury in those
again
i don't know if it's
a
i don't i doubt
one broken bulb would expose you to
enough mercury to
really [ __ ] you up it's probably more
mercury
yeah there's probably more mercury in a
salmon than that go ahead oh yeah that's
a good point i'm saying you have to plug
the mercury from dozens of bulbs
you'd have to correct yeah for it to be
dangerous
also i came home and went to bed how
being able to influence our land anymore
i called 9-1-1 and went to the emergency
room i was diagnosed as delusional so i
came home and went to bed what a
relief she's okay
but the whole premise i i how being a
micro influencer landed me in the
hospital
i guess she was looking for that clout
somebody the chad is now saying it's
satire but you know what yeah it's
definitely satire yeah
well let's see i mean let's see let's go
let's go
and find out if it's satire
honestly
when your best friend taps out on day
three of your
bender personal
because i once have done it you got to
mute that yeah
okay and whatever it's just audio i
don't know what to say there
bro can i just go okay honestly
i took it
[ __ ] person i wouldn't have done it
to you what is this this is not
this is not good content
shopping haul
i'm sorry but there's no evidence of
self-awareness i looked at a lot of her
other tick tocks and none of them seemed
like they were joking so i don't know
maybe that one randomly is a satire but
uh
but if she has the prince of mind to
create something so off the rails like
that
you would think that that would be
more pre here she's narrating this one
let's watch this one there's got to be
some goofs here
if getting married in toronto was in my
near future i would copy a lot of what
my cousin did for her wedding so come
get ready with me for my cousin's
wedding as a bridesmaid i woke up at 5am
to shower off myself tanner we met at
the bridal suite for six we stayed
overnight at the pearl hotel it was a
stunning brand new hotel on the water in
burlington we were the only people there
so it was almost as if we had our own
private hotel just for the wedding we
had mimosas coffee and bailey's and erin
steamed all of our dresses then we all
walked across the street to bubbles and
blow bar where we were getting our hair
and makeup done the salon owner did
everyone's hair except for
and a traveling makeup artist did
everyone's makeup they both did such a
good job i'm not exaggerating when they
say we all looked way better than we
ever looked we drank more mimosas eat
breakfast how stunning was my cousin
i've never in my life seen a prettier
ride and then we walked back over the
pearl hotel popped some more champagne
got dressed and then danced our way to
the venue yep she's serious
i'm sorry but that was a real video the
only thing that made me question it is
when she said i was washing off my self
tanner in the morning
was that weird no no you do that oh i
thought like self
tanner i don't know if she's doing it
you apply self-tanner you let it sit for
six hours you wash it off oh hi
i said go off queen she's making she's
pumping out content i wasn't making it
to my cousin's wedding
yeah that vocal fries
that's hardcore man i was going and i
got them writing and then i
i mean if the end she could have been
like fell off plus ratio by the way yeah
check
check if she is being you know ironic
she's not doing a good job at it because
it's
wait the chat is arguing that she's
being ironic they they've turned now
after that last video so so you're going
to chat and awesome and also i called
them boomer in the chat i said boomer
dan is going to war with chad everybody
somebody posted a
a thread on the subreddit that's just
gonna enable dan moore
here let me read it oh yeah
i got scared i was like i got scared too
i was like oh come on but it was
actually funny i'll read it
um come on where is it
why does the subreddit look so weird but
what does that mean she got diagnosed as
delusional
and went home they told her she's crazy
she said there's nothing wrong with you
you can't get mercury poisoning from
cleaning a lifeboat
you don't
have yes it is funny but i don't think
it was intentional oh man
you can't be diagnosed with
well she's a dumbass she doesn't know
how to describe things no
there's no evidence that it's a joke you
can't look in her entirety of her tick
tock and say this one tick tock
is some next level yeah you can't do
that maybe she's i think she's
yeah i think she's going next level
there yeah
well i disagree
you need more evidence
you need more evidence to support such a
theory you need more evidence
because the last one could have been
like uh
you know we went to the bridal shower
and uh we all got arrested for having a
uh for having asked on us anyway it was
a lot of fun like just something like
that if they were yeah if there were any
other videos that were in that same
comedic style
it would be really easy just to do that
i'm trying to find that post when
someone finds it out there are you
discord thank you maybe
if he's always on it
he reads my mind
which is all i ever want from you
i just want you to read my [ __ ] mind
i just look at you throughout the show
and just but you did in this case so i'm
happy
dan's treatment of members lately and i
saw this with like a thousand points
when it was up there and i was like
oh boy here we go
i get it members can be annoying in chat
but telling them to shut up calling them
annoying i'm leaving ethan out of this
because it usually says something that
stands up for them i'm a former member
now not because i'm offended just
because i'm broke as hell i just want to
say about dan the hater that he can go
right ahead and do that [ __ ] whenever he
wants it makes me alone every time you
know what they deserve it talk [ __ ] to
us king i live for it sorry this is
posted before my subreddit searches and
my heart sank when i saw this and it was
got halfway through it they got me good
yeah this was a great post by none other
than oracle oracle
shout outs
i'm gonna come
i'm gonna come
but um anyway no no poll guys sorry you
were wrong
a poll if it's real or fake i'll do a
poll i'll throw it to paul
yeah i'll authorize that
come on guys olivia is catering to the
chat i'm not catering
evidently
okay i understand thinking that it might
be a joke like i get it i want to
believe it
there's just not enough evidence you
would see other funny tick tocks and
these these people they think we don't
check these things like i didn't see the
one post and like immediately assume it
was real i looked through her tick tock
she doesn't have other joke videos well
you know wow the majority still think
they should satire okay then if she's
not in on the satire of the joke we are
and we still think it's not it's not a
sad warrior
if she's actually just a dumbass
we got to get her to call him
we're at 51.49 okay well there you go
you see this isn't everyone says the h3
uh community is just like misogyny
excuse me
i just saw that in the chat what yeah i
was saying that too maybe that's a joke
they're saying internalized massage
maybe i think that's out never mind
don't say it i'm not gonna say i will
say though that's the one thing when i
read that post about dan like my heart
stopped for a little bit too because
it's not my audience to talk [ __ ] to but
you know dan's been here long enough and
i
makes me so happy whenever he talks back
every so often it's your audience to
talk [ __ ] too i mean just you know no
it's not right
i stan chat in all conditions
i love every member
i love all of the members too i mean
it's it's it's banter especially it's
called keemstar who has five
subscriptions yeah yeah
yeah and let me say that too a lot of
people think whenever we complain we
think it's everyone it's like
one percent if even
but they're the annoying ones all right
it is the no's have edged out just oh
wait no it just went back i was going to
say
guys to everyone who says that h3
community is a bandwagon
i've come out i've put my neck out there
i've said this woman
is not satire and there you go people
vote against me
they have voted against me
independent-minded kings out there in
the chat saboteur yes is back
yes is back on top so there you go
we are independent yeah exactly we're
free thinkers we're a community of free
thinkers that's right
so shout outs
hell yes hell yes
all right and it's 50 50 we'll leave it
at that thank you
oh yeah do you see this is i have seen
this before it's great yeah nice ocean
view what do you guys think about this
you know living on the ocean is awesome
i was reading i was listening to the
news last night and they're saying about
how there's some crazy-ass glacier
that's you guys know the glaciers are
all melting and they're like the sea if
this thing goes the sea is going to rise
by like six feet in like five years
awesome
so i was like that's crazy bro
it's just hilarious how no one gives a
[ __ ] that like the ice is melting and
we're all bro just don't live near their
sea
yeah i mean
what did i saw i saw a real
ocean do you understand how crazy that
is six feet that's the height of
zach sorry zach 6-1 6-1
the whole
around the whole world is going to rise
this the height of zach i mean that's a
lot of water that's like hundreds of
years from now though no dude this whole
glacier is going it's going to be like
10 years to five years no
i'm telling you dude
i mean i don't believe me i know it's
bad but no it's fast it's bad a little
bit away half the ice in the arctic is
gone dude half well maybe i think there
were four do you think pangea will
happen again
that was like that had nothing to do
with ice i think so zach need to prepare
they could they say the continents are
moving closer yes it will happen again
in like i don't know a billion years
yeah maybe no
is this are you asking just separate
from the climate change discussion yeah
i mean i mean because yeah
what are you making fun of me for that
dan
doesn't have anything to do with climate
change yeah it goes that's that's figure
cycles because that has to do with
titanium
what do you figure tectonic plates
listen he's explaining it don't double
down
tectonic plates i mean they shift over
you know geological ages we're talking
like millions of years and yeah so
they're moving but we're talking like
two centimeters the molten core of our
earth shifts plates of the earth it's
called tectonic
movements tectonic plates so it doesn't
really have anything to do with the
climate how does that have to do with
environment and world and climate it has
well the climate has
science it has to do with the with the
core of our planet yeah like the earth
goes through cycles of being completely
frozen completely overtaken by lava
well the frozen has nothing to do with
pangaea that is right
but
it's ever-changing yes
but tectonic movements will never stop
that's independent of weather and
climate thank you zach
does that make sense to you
do you know about tectonic plates did
you learn about it yes i know about
tectonics so that's what it's about it's
not about carbon or anything in the in
the atmosphere yeah i'm still saying
climate change okay climate change stop
climate change no more pangaea hashtag
humans against pangaea yeah exactly what
do we got napoleon swam back it's shout
out dude imagine what em what pangaea
will do for immigration
oh yeah
very straight dude
bearing these nuts straight into your
mouth
got them
[Applause]
not you zack it's just uh we gotta we're
saying we gotta stop pandra you're right
we must
we have to figure out how to stop this
i'm so pumped for pangea i've already
got my tickets
no hottest festivals no we have to stop
pangaea it is going to
it is going to increase immigration into
this country there will be no more
borders how will we monitor our borders
with pangaea this is a can cataclysm my
friends
if climate change didn't happen the
titanic wouldn't have sunk
so true and think about that dude that's
true and jack and rose could have gotten
married i know they're absolutely
fictional but like it's also fictional
shout out titanic doug yeah
i'm not sure that's true zach
when was the titanic launch titan 1912
19 yeah i mean there was definitely some
trending of increased garment obviously
by then but i don't think there was any
uh well they were going into the north
atlantic there's icebergs there so yeah
but i think there's always icebergs
right yeah there was a bunch of factors
well you had the industrial revolution
started and you know sure yeah they
didn't bring the binoculars yeah
shut up what are you a [ __ ] titanic
[Music]
once i went with this girl i was talking
to she wanted to go watch titanic at the
[ __ ] movies and we went to the movies
and it wasn't the actual titanic there's
a [ __ ] documentary at the imax about
the titanic that's awesome
so that makes you an expert
i wanted to see [ __ ] leo and imax i i
myself am actually a big fan of the
titanic not the movie i i know a lot of
the ship the shift that's deep
deeper than it sink dude
i made the joke before you could
[ __ ]
so um
anyway anyway
just saying
just saying just saying
so anyway here anyway speaking of uh the
the ocean raising six feet in the next
five years
what are they doing eating breakfast
there
in these types of conditions like what
are they doing
time to go
yeah and you know this poor restaurant
is gonna be
underwater and about
this is awesome though
guys this is no time for brunch
the ocean is rising damn it
pangaea's right around the corner
i'll be honest i think that video was
satire
the tick tock
yeah no this one oh
i'm asking the community pulls up
if this video sat there
the ocean is making a joke
it should have been is the ocean kidding
that's no joke that's no joke
what are we gonna do without ice
the ice glaciers are melting
the ocean is rising you can't even eat
brunch with a beautiful ocean view
anymore
what are we gonna do without brunch by
the ocean
it's outrageous
these chefs these restaurant owners are
doing impossible things
they're on stilts damn it
they've got a whole building on stilts
[Music]
we've got to freeze those [ __ ]
glaciers
[Music]
i'm calling on everybody
on december 18th at 12 o'clock everybody
open your refrigerator at once
we're gonna cool this [ __ ] down
everybody point your ac outside
what are we gonna do without ice
look at this [ __ ]
look at this [ __ ]
the [ __ ]
[Music]
the ocean is angry
it doesn't want us eating brunch
god damn it
what do i got if not brunch it's [ __ ]
outrageous
crispy bacon
with an ocean view
it's not right
the titanic would have never sank if
those damn icebergs would have stayed
frozen
[Music]
that [ __ ]
the unsinkable bear brown mary or
whatever the [ __ ] her name was took that
spot jack could have had it he was a
young man he had his whole life before
him
[Music]
that [ __ ] unsinkable [ __ ]
she's old enough they could have lived
free titanic together
and don't get me started on rose that
selfish [ __ ]
there was plenty of room on that door
[Music]
what are we gonna do without jack what
are we gonna do without jack
and the [ __ ] ice is melting god damn
it don't get me started on pangaea
i got your word straight jack
jack get your word straight jack
yeah there you go
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] over it
i'm goddamn over it
[Music]
maybe i should introduce something more
than meat to my diet
very unstable
[ __ ]
thank you
[Music]
thank you everyone
that [ __ ] took the heart of the ocean
and she threw it
and she threw it in the damn ocean that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh no i we could have had the heart of
the ocean
she threw it in the ocean what was she
thinking
jack wouldn't have wanted you to throw
it in the ocean like that you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what are we gonna do without men
and they're
big diamonds it's unfair
it's unfair
why didn't they cast at least
if they would have given her a smaller
door we wouldn't be obsessed with the
fact that there was space for two
why they let the women and children go
first
toxic masculinity the women and the
children go first the men are doing
impossible things
[Music]
they're dying in the engine room
they're playing the violin as the ship
goes down
[Music]
they do everything and these [ __ ]
entitled kids i want to live too
and that unsinkable brown yeah your ass
wouldn't be so unsinkable if you were a
man
if you were a man your ass would be on
the bottom of the ocean right next to
the heart of the ocean you [ __ ]
[Music]
but for real why'd they make the door so
big if they would have just made it a
one-person sized door
this whole debate
it could have solved everything what
year is it
what the [ __ ] this is awesome here i was
on the titanic
i was on the titanic buddy
i know what happened there
dude
no jordan peterson literally dressed
like a pickup artist no wonder
[Music]
is that really he looks so
different this is him younger looks
german i think he lost a lot of weight
being stung by a bee in his eye or
something
i got bags under my eyes because i'm
just so [ __ ] pissed
about all these women what cabin do you
think uh dr p or someone being
what do you mean low level mid-level
i'm a man what do you think i'm first to
die
i'm on the bottom
saw those two making love in the car i
beat off watching through the window
they never saw me
was that your handprint
i saw the handprint
it's crazy how big the door argument is
because in rose's defense
they show him trying to get on as well
and it he barely tried he tried but
that's it's there to show that they're
both going to get on they shouldn't have
made the door so big
it could have been smaller because
they've both gotten on that i don't know
i feel like he attempts to get on they
could have sunk it if they were both
sitting on it that's right yeah well his
ass leaning off ain't helping anybody
either well i think they should have
taken turns i feel like he had to do
that to control it
so well he's no his ass sunk to the
bottom and she just floated
they can't they can't swap i mean it
wouldn't have helped they would have
both died i mean it's too late now you
know
she lived her life though her heart went
on yeah i'm sorry but if she scooted
over did go on yeah i mean yeah if he
probably if you
the thing is she looks all cold and
frostbitten now but at the time she had
some vitality
like that's after her his ass we've been
sitting in the arctic ocean for [ __ ]
hours
you know i'm sorry bro
i don't buy it all right bro
here let's see
look how they're just like oh yeah it's
all good look at this it's all good
just gonna take a nap his legs are fine
i'm just chilling
in the northern atlantic
i mean look here they both are on it
shout out to that pool in burbank
nice warm wet water probably
you know i hated it when i was younger
but you grow up and you you appreciate
it
i liked it yeah i liked it back then
i loved that movie
i mean i haven't seen it in a while
i've seen it like three times and i
always
stop it
right after the car scene because then
it's
a happy ending
wait the car scene
oh that car scene because when i was a
kid i remember watching and like
panicking and crying
so now i'm just like i don't know you're
probably too young for that movie then
correct
yeah your parents did you dirty it was
terrifying in the when the
door closed you know
and then oh when there's the water's
filling yep you wanna hear some wild
[ __ ] somebody just donated 20 to say
that's not how buoyancy works okay well
what's this chart i just found
look at this they did a whole damn study
oh
really look at this
how can two people fit on this piece of
wood
what it's not about fitting
it's about the weight well look how they
distribute the weight they figured it
out perfect distribution of weight well
they didn't have time to run these
experiments before it's just saying they
didn't even try episode of mythbusters
says cam looked into this oh they did
what was the result
you can't remember that's the most
important you can't what's the point
if you can't remember
well
what a myth bust did they bust this or
what
they found out the titanic is actually
satire this titanic isn't real
oh this is a screenshot from mythbusters
oh i see yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah
there's this is literally someone wrote
a whole article about this about
buoyancy
about uh let's see it's an age-old
debate i mean this has been a debate
since
elementary school for me can you not bro
please okay thank you um
so wait they're going to make a
conclusion here
made of oak they got the perspective
they're doing the math they're doing the
buoyancy
this is quite impressive this is very
detailed
so if the panel is made of oak it could
only hold rows
as 1992
plus five
five four nine
which is just enough for rose to stay
afloat above the water level
okay so they're saying
um there you have it not even the power
of love can overcome the cold-hearted
brutal law of the universe so according
to this they're saying according this
tumblr post with three likes i don't
know they did that dude they did them no
i mean it looks pretty thorough they did
the math that's pretty thorough they're
saying only rose could could it could
hold her weight so
there you have it damn damn the real
debate
is at the end of the movie is she
dreaming or does she go to heaven
that's the real deal she threw the
diamond after when she goes and she goes
to bed
it looks like she's sleeping but
also she's on the titanic and like she
sees jesus
dude she was like 100 years old i know
for sure he ain't there i don't think
i've ever seen that part well because
you never got past the sex scenes
do you remember this part of the sex
scene olivia
say it again do you remember this part
of this one
yeah i do i watched those two in that
car
i had my dick in my hand
go get her bucko
he did pretty good with her butt i could
tell he was inexperienced bend her over
yeah
i was shouting notes to him
[Music]
concessive seems to be that she died by
the way
yeah i think she'll some people saying
she didn't i think she went to heaven
and he was waiting for her because the
clock in the background wasn't moving he
went that high then what is this a
religious wait wait what what what
interpretation the thing about the clock
that wasn't working the clock wasn't
moving behind him the clock wasn't
working
he was waiting for her in heaven [ __ ]
beautiful next question
do you think he really wants to hit that
old ass
what's he going to do with her in heaven
break her hip
[ __ ] that that'd be so [ __ ] if he was
still young and she was old as [ __ ] well
of course how's he going to be older he
didn't live
you ripped to billy zane my dog
did he die no but like he in the titanic
well he was at the battle yeah
he was the baddie he was the badass guy
but like he died like nevermind
who cares if she died zach the type of
dude to root for billy zane and titanic
shout out billy zayn dawg
he had a few rollies
uh how being a micro
the restaurant let's see what else we
got the joker laugh okay
let's move on to the joker laugh
it's taking us like an hour to get
through every 30 second clip
okay this one goes out to that okay
the joker yeah i've been told that my
laugh is very reminiscent of the joker
the joker yeah
no way
[Music]
that sounds like jack
this is when zach got his booster shot
i hear it i think yeah
this is just cringe though right yes it
is
this is hard to watch it's pretty good
i'm confused why why did this come to be
was he hitting on her was yeah i think
he's hitting i think he's trying to
impress her or make her laugh or
something
but man
[Music]
[Laughter]
and she's obviou she's obviously
uncomfortable enough to be filming
herself
dude are you still on the clock
yeah okay go [ __ ] work i just i need
a drink i can't breathe
i can't [ __ ] breathe
it's like what the [ __ ] why so serious
oh my god guys it's obviously satire
god
that was the work that was bad
that was rough
oh that was rough that was a bad one
brutal
oh
oh wow
oh wow
oh wow
play that let's do a competition oh wow
let's see who can do shatner the best oh
my do oh wow
[Music]
oh i'm telling you
oh i'm telling you
oh
wow
i'm telling you
oh i'm telling you weightlessness
weightlessness
i can't believe this
i can't believe this
oh my goodness me
oh my goodness me
oh jesus oh jesus oh [ __ ] oh
jesus
oh oh i'm telling you
oh i'm telling you
thank you
oh i'm telling you
oh jesus
oh jesus
oh i'm telling you
oh my goodness me oh my goodness me
oh i'm telling you
hey it's a little clogged up on that one
isn't he a skateboarding on a dead car
okay
let's see what's in store for us here
all right my car is dead
so i'm gonna skateboard down this hill
just like that
yeah i have a problem yeah boy
controlling it
[Music]
dude what the [ __ ] oh shoot this is
actually
very dangerous yeah um so there's a
definitely
oh [ __ ] i don't have to wait my door's
open oh [ __ ] bro what though
i better bail
[Music]
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
guys my bush light is gone oh [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
oh well this car is screwed
thanks for sticking around guys
damn how are you that dog oh that was
[ __ ] dumb
that was the dumbest [ __ ] i've ever done
yeah
oh
wow
wow
wow
this was okay
yeah that's true no
so what was it was he holding on to the
door was he on top of the car
it seemed to me i think he had all right
my car is dead oh he said the door was
closed right because he was gonna
skateboard the door's open now
it's just like that
yeah did he not realize he was about to
go down a hill or something did he
i just i don't understand you can see
his foot here zach he's
got one foot
on the frame here
and one foot on the ground he's pushing
like a skateboard and he's holding on to
the door dude
and holding a camera on his other hand
dude
he had a good opportunity to get in
there and push the brakes and feel like
you think you just panicked
oh shoot doesn't even grab the wheel if
you need to stay just one hand um he's
narrating about how dangerous is instead
of acting when he had a chance so
there's a good camera work though
considering
true
[ __ ]
it's not that keemstar he's got that
right swiss army knife
definitely
oh [ __ ] i don't have my my door's open
oh [ __ ]
i think what happens at the end is he is
reaching in and turning the wheel and
the moment the momentum of it turning
right causes him to he swipes out yeah
he swings out the door right yeah
i mean i would have bailed at this point
holy [ __ ]
oh well this car is screwed
thanks for sticking around guys
damn
what's the story here like i actually
want to know who is this guy
and what the [ __ ] was that guys my busch
light is gone what is busch light it's a
beer oh he was drunk that helps expand
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] balls
is he an influencer or like what i guess
there's i'm going to be a micro yeah
yeah that's micro influencer behavior
right there this is satire
oh no
that's gonna be the new meme
[Music]
i don't know if this is incredible but
i'm seeing someone comment on reddit
that uh he went to school with this kid
and it came from a wealthy family and he
was known for doing crazy stunts like
this
so what's satire happen in my hometown
in upstate new york buffalo
we got a buffalo kid this is buffalo
behavior for sure
that's a cheap car though that's a very
cheap looking car yeah it's a honda crx
yeah
no respect for those
they run forever though unless you slam
it into embankment
i'm looking for something great because
how long we've been going dan well we've
been going for
uh one hour 32 minutes and four seconds
yeah so we're running out of time i'm
looking for one last good thing like
we've got
woman spitting and sealing chips at
supermarket that's the old one gabby
hannah talks about the vlog squad
calling her fat logan paul late to his
own pocket did you see melania's nft and
and then there's that one you want to do
that i feel like that's quick and pretty
good okay you got to see the actual uh
with the audio file the trump family has
finally at long last
join the nft
craze she is excited for this new
venture our former first lady and future
first lady
melania trump excited for this new
venture which combines my passion for
art
and commitment to helping our nation's
children fulfill their own unique dream
of america
wow sounds lofty
she's pleased to announce that uh
the nft platform which will release
nfts and regular intervals exclusively
at melania trump.com
melania's vision that will be called
will be available for purchase for a
limited period between december 16 and
december nobody this is going to be like
the um
wait it's the 17th can we see we have
updates
i feel like this is going to be a bit
redemption type of situation well you go
the next link in the doc is the link to
where it's being sold and you can see it
and there's an audio
associated with it as well
so it's a full audio visual experience
should i finish reading this statement
cares so here's the website
let's see what's melania's nft here
limited time baby
it's a loading
it's just a ad block situation no my
vision is there it is look forward with
inspiration
strength
and courage
that's it
that's the nft yeah would you like to
buy that for two hundred dollars and she
did all this press release and all this
[ __ ] about help why is she talking about
helping kids uh a portion of the process
not even all of it no not all but a
portion of the proceeds will go to some
kids somewhere who knows
family
by the way
when they say abortion that could be
nothing that could be one percent like
if it was a substantial amount she would
say
the amount
that's my take i'm scammed yeah because
you only say portion because you're not
giving and like hardly any
so
because it would look tacky as [ __ ] for
her just to do this for profit
but she is i mean it could be like just
a few percent
but what does one soul mean
journey has been enlightening
from slovenia through europe and into
america
including the first lady
the beauty and hardships of individuals
majestic landscapes and profound
architectures have entered
her lens and remained in her heart you
know she's like dude
michelle obama is killing it out there i
need to get my
i need to get mine right but she doesn't
want to do like speeches well nobody
wants to pay her for any [ __ ] she like
what the [ __ ] she gonna do wait
wasn't she when uh trump got nominated
she got
she at the rnc gave a speech and it was
like directly lifted from michelle
obama's oh yes yes so she should do a
speaking tour and just do
michelle's material i just don't think
she's as inspiring i just don't think
people are going to pay to watch her oh
look at that maybe she should sell line
it up line it up
yeah oh oh wow
oh that looks good
give me a freak i
hey melania it's almost christmas what
do you think about christmas
is that demi lovato wait hold on melania
say that again
yeah if i go to fox they will do the
story
wait what did you say about christmas
christmas stuff
wow that is blasphemy christmas is the
most important
day of the christian faith how dare you
gives a [ __ ] about christmas
it's amazing
oh and then don't forget be bad might be
best initiative what
that's why i love this i love be best
it's so [ __ ] good because her husband
is the most prolific bully of all time
be best
led by compassion
strength and kindness
these qualities are the fabric of our
nation
and allows you to really opportunity
[Music]
in wanting to create a better future
for our next generation
look forward with inspiration look
strength
incorporation
courage
strength
oh here what is an nft this is great
she's educating the people oh good
and why purchase an nft
when purchasing an nft the buyer is
receiving a unique and secure digital
asset
just like a baseball card
how do i purchase an nft three steps
create a digital wallet add
cryptocurrency to your digital wallet in
this case solana
and then just click buy nft can you
imagine a boomer who's trying to buy
this [ __ ] being like like this is the
hardest thing i think for anyone who'd
be interested in buying this to ever do
yeah good luck just create a digital
wallet that's like
and then buy cryptocurrency that's
you're basically asking them to build
the eiffel tower by themselves
do you remember her uh
her christmas decorations at the white
house
how it looked like it was like a hallway
from
the emperor's palace in star wars or
something yeah reminds me of like uh
um what was that one they recreated with
the with the a uh the robots with
harrison ford
oh um
oh blade runner yeah it's like a blade
run machine
dystopian christmas sick
what is a smart contract royalty
we do a little trolling it's called by
the way she's got the resale royalty on
you can always send an nft as a gift
without any reoccurring fee
but if you sell the nft to a third party
there will be a ten percent transaction
fee
to yours truly
having a full year i get a i gotta wet
my beak a little on this stuff you guys
understand look at this [ __ ]
my first beautiful why you really
snapped today
[Laughter]
do you support coin bases on her af faq
coinbase is a crypto exchange if you
build a solana wallet you can instantly
transfer sol from coinbase account
do you support oh they're saying can i
use it
yo they've got everything here
awesome
yeah well if you guys are interested in
uh
purchasing this limited edition
my vision is
look forward with inspiration
strength
and courage
wow
i'm on i'm gonna cry
say please make sure your sound is
turned on to listen to this nft
oh my god
it's just beautiful
can we see how many of these have have
she sold it says current supplies
1132. can we see how many she sold love
you're pretty good at the blockchain
stuff
oh here
transaction history
oh yeah she's she's selling them
well not that many of them
check this out
you want to see a crime committed right
now
sure
oh no got it well luckily it's not it's
not grand theft because it's only 175
right it's under that but if you
download that four times your ass is
going to jail
so don't even think about it
don't even [ __ ] think about it
oh oh my journey
yeah
uh can you are you trying to see
it says trent since sexual transfer
is this it says successful transactions
1734 did you sell that many of that
uh yeah probably i just see in the past
days she sold one two three four five
five of them today
and yesterday she sold four i mean
that's not that crazy i mean the first
lady she's she'll call myself four in a
day
that's micro influencer [ __ ]
she's in her flop era yeah
i think trump in general is in his flop
area and it's he'll be back he'll be
back he'll be back don't worry
perpetually it'll be pop era
he'll be back i'll be back
so lana or do we have to go yeah i have
to go
okay short one today
and there's no episodes this
weekend because we did live on thursday
so raw we'll have behind the scenes
today oh yeah so thank you of course to
our members even though danielle's at
you no we love you all members we love
each and every i love you individually
and um members get episodes early when
we pre-record them which we didn't do
this week
this was a
full set of live episodes kind of wild
wait well what you also get is the
community discord and a weekly bts
made by ab
thank you a b and um there's going to be
a new one
today after this app
is that it
that's right
with the footage of you
right in the bowl right
so
there's some footage oh yeah you're
riding the ball hassan's in here we got
amaranth
you reading kevin all's tweet for the
first time finding out the fbi's coming
for you oh right
a lot of good stuff
i love that
yes so become a member if you want to
watch that bts and we'll be back so next
week's our last week
we're going to be doing an episode on
monday
off the r
whatever h
tv on monday and then wednesday is our
last
year after dark
is our last episode it's going to be a
very special live episode white club
gabe will be here white cloud game we're
going to have a special i'm telling you
guys are not going to miss that final
episode of the year and
can we tease
ian we're doing your whole thing on next
wednesday right yeah that's right
everybody oh yeah remember from last
year craig's miss was a huge hit that's
the origin of the cursed cosby doll and
all that kind of good stuff
well ian's done it again folks and uh
i don't know all i don't know my own i
don't know all of them but i know some
of them and there's some
real
craigs
back yep and that's not even the big uh
that's not even the big one the big
thing we've been working on yeah we've
got a lot of things going on so very
excited for that episode but i hope you
guys have a great weekend
there's plenty of content to catch up on
if you run out there's like 20 billion
hours of content this week alone
for real
and uh well we love you it's a pleasure
to uh
to create for you and to
family it up family family family
family family
family family family friends family
family family family
somebody i saw somebody
in the comments the other day
say that we should shout out who made i
guess that's a content creator that made
that video with all the vin diesels wait
i thought we did it was the vin diesel
guy no
i think he was just participating in it
okay yeah we should shout him out yeah
uh cause that clip just went viral and
we just saw it
somewhere or whatever we didn't see it
from there today
family family family
thought so too uh
family family family
family family family family family i
mean family family family family
i'm looking for it but it's so viral
that's the thing like there's a million
uploads of it
and well next week we can we'll figure
it out shout out shout out to whoever
came up with that it's brilliant we love
it we'll give them a big shout out at
the top of the show yeah oh so oh that's
right donut media is their name somebody
in the chat knew thank you shout out
donutmedia
uh hopefully you haven't assaulted
anybody or anything oh well let's give
him a big shout out at the top of the
show
going up media uh next week dan or a b
make a note
i love them oh you know them
yeah it's like a car youtube channel oh
for real
yeah and they created that but anyway
let's find the original video ab
next week at the top of the show we'll
give them a big shout out all right
unload it now
oh i see their banner
i guess it makes sense if he's doing a
fast and furious move you see their
banner
is all the guys there you go
well shout out it's an amazing video and
we've
so we'll figure out a lot of
entertainment from it yeah thank you
donut
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family
with family family family family
i think maybe it looks so good like that
is this video a little late by the way
this is from two weeks ago paul walker
everything you need to know
uh
i don't know everything about paul
working necessarily and i imagine i'm
not alone out there as somebody that
doesn't know the full breadth of things
that you should know about paul walker
so
not a time sensitive
video
no not necessarily i mean
1.1 million people um
found that helpful so i think there were
some well in fact you're on my account
can you save that for later yeah i'm
gonna watch that
i feel like there was some involvement
with paul walker's brother with the
future release or something recently so
maybe that's why
here let's see is his back
humanitarianism or is it something
harder to pin down like being the right
person to make the right moves at the
right time maybe it's everything well
for car nerds all over the world myself
don't get sucked into this you gotta go
here included you gotta go
okay
express some peace to the greatest all
right
all right
walk with the angels
people made that people say that right i
can't be the one who says that
rip paul walker walk with the angels oh
the first time i've heard it but it
sounds beautiful yeah walk with paul
paul walking with god
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the ashes like the phoenix on the flex
back to two